somebody who can firewall themselves
from a whole lot of group play if
there's so much groupthink out there
there's so many people that are
repeating opinions have become a rules
that were never and and there's so much
defaulting the people who ever resume
jizz have a success that I've done it
this this this way so this is the way
you should do it and then all of us do
it that way and then none of us realize
hey we're all doing the same thing how
and purpose we're all volunteering to do
the same why don't like no one's going
to six no one in show business succeeds
the exact same way there's some
parallels but I think that's the thing
is like this is an archaic mess this is
not a linear line this is I've worked on
things in this direction thinking this
is the right thing and then I realize oh
my god why am I wasting my 2 i'm doing
that and go this way but it's not but I
stayed with vampire Club I just changed
how I was doing things a vampire nah
they didn't change the story I stuck
with one story if I kept changing shows
and never would have seen that long tail
because of that spike mentality if I
made vampire ma put it out when Oh
nobody likes it next door but up nobody
likes it but nobody likes it waiting for
what some magical beam to go you're so
good luck here's some money go make some
stories that doesn't happen that hard
think is the thing about it five years
almost like eight years just on this
I've got 20 playing the other day doing
what I was supposed to do winning
contests getting literary managers and
doing all that bull I did all that
it's no fun for me it was no
fun it didn't work I didn't get the tell
any stories I got to get rejected and
not to tell any stories for years so I'm
not going to do that again because that
didn't work I see this working but it
takes a long much longer than most
people are gonna wait in three years
again family guy canceled for three
years rest of elements seven years
that's when that audience build the
content was out the same granted plumber
episodes and I know a lot more night
like an hour and 15 minutes of story and
then a whole a couple more hours of
extras and behind the scenes and
interviews and all the rest of it so got
a decent chunk of content for one story
but I'm one guy and I can't keep putting
this thing out it's too big vampire mom
is too big for me to do it unassisted I
wrote myself into a corner I click off
we were going to go in a certain
direction and
and I'm not going to make that mistake
again on with the next project is like
because I need bet that scale the other
part of this when you make a movie
everything's gotta work a lot of stuffs
got to work for a very short amount of
time the next project is an anthology
series called play shorts where its
individual sports that are plays that
I've written that are seen performed on
stage of the last almost four years now
at the rustling theater in Santa Monica
so I'm taking slightly 40 of those plays
written so have 40 individual short
strips that have been tested in front of
an audience just sitting there doing
nothing so I've been going through and
picking out the ones I like the ones at
work and gonna inspired by Playhouse 90
going to shoot anthology series
different characters different locations
different stories different actors and
if I can only raise enough money to
shoot three of them I only shoot three
of them by shooting up money that I can
raise enough money shoot eight of them
then we'll make a toes and and that way
I can grow in a way where I don't need
to raise fifty thousand a hundred
thousand fails not be able to raise that
money get active burn nations bats
so what I'm hoping is that I clean build
the play shirts audience while the
vampire model audience continues to grow
and then start working on more than one
stories start switching back
independently all with just the audience
dominating and ebay auctions and
t-shirts and whatever else to raise the
money pasma audience keeps getting
bigger the number of people that need to
donate for me to be able to make sure
exit to ground is smaller because now
I'm talking to you know this group of
people instead of this yeah but it's
taken years to and I didn't talk about
to all those months that have gone by
the show my real I talked about it a lot
but I had to talk about something else
because otherwise
hate myself i would appeal tab or read
my own tuna sand oh here's Joe against
and I tweet a lot the same stuff cuz
there's new people to follow the show
all the time so I always say to the new
people hi welcome I see you you exist hi
and people you know okay yeah Joe say oh
my god now we have old-timers sound like
oh yeah I've known you since 2010 wave
better way back in 2010 when we first
met oh yeah it was the old days right
wow that's wow that seems like it seems
like a better business call
you